well few people predicted last year the
coronavirus would last as long as they
have or that they would cause as much
damage to the united states as they have
one person who did predict this was
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
he came on this show one year ago this
week an issue the following warning
i'm going to do everything i can to live
but you know
if you said are you willing to take a
chance you know if i get sick i'll go
and try to get better but if i don't i
don't and i'm not trying to think in any
kind of morbid way tucker
but i'm just saying that that um we've
got a choice here
and and we're going to be in a total
collapse
recession depression collapse in our
society if this goes on
another several months there won't be
any jobs to come back to for many people
so for saying that out loud dan patrick
was
savaged hundreds of pieces written about
him and how he was insane and ignoring
the science that's what happens when you
say things that are true
so a year after he said that we thought
it would be interesting to
invite lieutenant governor dan patrick
back on the show to assess
everything that's happened over the past
year lieutenant governor dan patrick
good to see you tonight thanks so much
and thanks for
for your remarks a year ago which i
think have held up very very well
um so as you look back back over 12
months
what are you seeing what's changed well
tucker
america is totally different a year ago
tonight
we were a different america at that
point in time
trump looked like a shoe-in we were not
nearly as racially divided as we are
today
mobs had not taken over the street there
were no autonomous zones
most businesses frowned on most of their
workforce working from home
as parents couldn't imagine virtual
schools and socialism
didn't have america by the throat and
biden at that time was a shaky candidate
who no one knew who would win the
nomination today is a shaky president
who's taking a wrecking ball to our
constitution
and to our liberty to our freedom he's
destroying everything that this country
was built
upon you know tucker after world war ii
after the civil war after 9 11 those
were
dark periods in our history difficult
times
our country changed our people changed
but we came out
better for it tucker we were stronger we
were resilient
we were united this time this dark
period is the first time
we're coming out in worse shape in a
much
dire situation because of now this
change
uh to socialism that has happened in
a blink of an eye 12 months
and authoritarianism i mean attacking
people in their skin color
throwing your political opponents into
jail which they have done a lot
um i never thought i'd see it here i
have to ask you what role do you think
looking back the coveted lockdowns
played in these changes that was the
first big change
sure well the other thing that i talked
about with you a year ago on the show
we've been on with you since but a year
ago when we talked about that
i said we have to be able to do two
things take care of our seniors
protect them and new york obviously
didn't governor cuomo didn't
but take care of our seniors because we
knew then tucker
the first month into it they were the
most vulnerable and then secondly
everyone else had to keep working we had
to keep america going
and so if you look at texas and florida
the two states that have led the way of
doing that
protecting our seniors the best we could
and keep
our country or our states open compare
us to new york
which is a shell of itself in the city
and in the state look at california
they're locked down and their numbers
are not much better in some cases worse
than ours
in terms of the pandemic so america
listened to
those who said go hide have no hope
live in fear and they created chaos
during this time
and and that's what socialism feeds upon
it creates fear and it creates chaos and
today
you know are we on the road to perdition
that we can't come back from
i know you i watch you a lot i know
that's heavily on your heart and in your
mind
and i don't know the answer to that but
i know this i believe in the american
people
i believe unlike the left who hates
america and
preaches that every day i believe most
americans love this country
we've always done better we've learned
from our past
we're a better country today than we
were 50 years ago or 100 years ago on
many of these issues
you've talked about tonight so i'm
counting on the american people to turn
back it's really not even politics
tucker it's not even republican democrat
we need some democrats to stand up you
know when
they wanted to impeach andrew johnson in
1868 i think it was
it was edmund ross a republican who cast
the vote
that stopped the impeachment he stood up
and at that time it was a very
instrumental
moment in our country not to go down
that road we need whether it's mansion
or cinema
we need some democrats in the senate to
stand up
for american values look mansion
represents a republican state
in west virginia and there are a lot of
republicans in arizona although it
didn't go for trump this time
so they need to stand up we need some we
need some heroes right now the democrat
party to stand up against
the socialist leftist progressive
angry people who hate this country in
their party
because i don't think all democrats in
this country believe what their leaders
are saying and we need
their party to stand up against joe
biden
you're i think you're exactly right and
there are a lot of really great people
decent people great moderate people in
this country in both parties and they do
need to stand up right now i agree with
that governor david
stanton for coming back thank you thank
you tucker amen